50 50 odds that these winds are going to
calm down a little bit as we get through
the morning hours they actually will now
they won't be the 50-plus we don't have
to face that today but definitely still
they are between 30 and 40 miles an hour
you can see the cameras shaking around
at least we can see the mountains thank
goodness couldn't do that yesterday with
all the dust that was in the air right
now we've got 48 degrees we've had some
patchy clouds around a lot of those are
moving out and i think we should have a
fair amount of sunshine back today look
at the dew point it's one degree what
that means is there's no moisture in the
air it is super dried out because of
those strong northwest winds overnight
they change direction back before
midnight right now at the airport
northwest sustained winds at 22 miles an
hour that just reinforces how dry the
air is out there sunrise at 6 11 sunset
at 7 12. so please keep yourself
hydrated get the big water bottle going
today make sure the kids are drinking
water i know they're out of school so
they're not in that routine but just
being out about maybe playing outdoors a
little bit today just make sure they're
drinking lots of water especially if you
have allergies that's going to dehydrate
you even more 49 at nellis 43 at
centennial hills 45 mountains edge a lot
of 40s around town this is colder air
moving in it's probably our last big
cold blast of the season we usually get
it in early april so i can't imagine
that we're going to have one this chilly
again before the warmer temperatures
really start setting in and take hold
look at cali india at 33 but ely's at
seven degrees we've got 20s in totopah
and reno also the north winds too making
it feel even cooler 21 in cedar city
mesquite's at 50 38 at indian springs 42
in perum right now sandy valley at 42
and we've got some pretty strong north
winds in lofland and bullhead city 59
boulder city's at 48. so top wins last
night red rock near 60 mile an hour
winds blue diamond near 55
50 plus that was after midnight up in
north las vegas and harry reid has been
close to 50 as well i had tornadoes in
northeastern arkansas reports of
baseball-sized hail also associated with
these thunderstorms in the eastern half
of the country looking for more severe
weather there today so our cold fronts
to the south that's open the door for
the cool air
there is some snow making its way over
towards denver i don't think the sierra
got nearly as much snow as they were
hoping for but they did get some and the
wind advisories and wind high wind
warnings those have expired for our area
still in place for eastern arizona and
parts of southern california there were
86 mile an hour winds along u.s 93.95
yesterday five mile canyon and barstow
had near 70 mile an hour winds it's no
wonder all that dust was being carried
up into southern nevada so 63 is as high
as we're going to go today that's down
from near 80 yesterday so quite a drop
with that cold front the winds will calm
down overnight we'll look for lighter
winds 70s returning tomorrow 80s by
friday through easter weekend really
should be a nice easter weekend but
breezy winds return on saturday before
easter sunday